You know, when we think about folds, it comes up with folds and unfolds and things like that. You think about monoids, right? And you think about the addition over the integers, let's say, right? And then you think what's the inverse of addition? Well, you think subtraction, but it's really the same thing as addition, just with the negative numbers, I guess. And so from there you get the idea of like the inverse is an element of the set. It's not a function, right? So there's that.
你知道，当我们想到折叠（fold）时，就会想到折叠、展开（unfold）之类的东西。你会想到幺半群（monoid），对吧？然后你会想到整数加法，比如说，对吧？接着你会想加法的逆运算是什么？嗯，你会想到减法，但其实它和加法是一回事，只不过是用负数来表示，我想是这样。所以从这里你就会得到一个概念，即逆元是集合中的一个元素。它不是一个函数，对吧？所以情况就是这样。
Maybe that's not what you were asking, but there's something else that just occurred to me. Like if we're talking about monoids and then extending that to semi-groups and groups, then the idea of an inverse is not that you have an inverse operation, but that you have inverse elements in your set for the operation. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 272 recorded on February 4, 2006. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Ben, we chat about algorithm inverses, monoids, infinity, and more. How's it going? You know, all right, surviving. surviving you know not not great but but everything's okay just just the trials of life the trials is this personally or do you mean like the macro picture of the world uh oh all of the above yeah i've just come back from the just come back from the vet oh no so it's nine o'clock in the
也许这不是你想问的，但我刚才想到了另一件事。比如，如果我们讨论幺半群，然后将其扩展到半群和群，那么逆元的概念就不是指你有一个逆运算，而是指你的集合中存在该运算的逆元素。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，这是 2006 年 2 月 4 日录制的第 272 期节目。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Ben 将聊聊算法逆运算、幺半群、无穷大等等。最近怎么样？你知道，还行，在维持生活。维持生活，你知道，不算太好，但一切都还好，只是生活的考验。这是指个人生活，还是指宏观世界？呃，以上皆是。是的，我刚从兽医那里回来。哦，不。所以现在是早上九点。
morning here i had to go to the vet early with one of my guinea pigs are they okay well we'll see they're at the vet they're in an oxygen box oh no So with guinea pigs, it's always a bit, they're very, they can be very fragile. And because they're prey animals, they don't, they don't show their illnesses or maladies, right? They hide them. So by the time you notice, like, she only started going downhill last night, really. Oh, wow. Took her in first thing this morning.
早上好，我不得不一大早就带着我的一只豚鼠去看兽医。它们还好吗？嗯，我们看看吧，它们在兽医那里，在氧气箱里。哦，不。对于豚鼠来说，总是有点……它们非常脆弱。而且因为它们是猎物动物，它们不会表现出自己的疾病或不适，对吧？它们会隐藏起来。所以当你注意到的时候，比如，她昨晚才开始恶化，真的。哦，天哪。今天一早我就带她去了。
I'm sorry to hear that. But, you know, hope for the best. Fingers crossed. All right, all the listeners send your. Best wishes to which guinea pig is this, because I know you have. Magdalena is her name. Magdalena. She came with it.
听到这个我很遗憾。但是，你知道，希望一切顺利。祈祷吧。好吧，所有的听众都送上你们的祝福。这是哪只豚鼠，因为我知道你有……她的名字叫 Magdalena。Magdalena。她来的时候就叫这个名字。
Maggie. All right, well, hopefully we hear good news. Hopefully. Yeah. My family's cat passed away a few months ago, but, I mean, she went by, I think her official name was Professor Minerva, McGonical, but obviously no one called. Right. called her that. We just called her Kit Kit. But she lived, I swear to God, it was like 19 or something.
Maggie。好吧，希望我们能听到好消息。希望如此。是的，我家的猫几个月前去世了，但是，我是说，她过去……我想她的正式名字是 Minerva McGonagall 教授，但显然没人那样叫她。对。叫她那个名字。我们只是叫她 Kit Kit。但我发誓，她活了大概 19 岁还是多少。
She was, yeah, yeah. Lived a very, very full life. So as sad as it is. Well, guinea pigs live five plus years. Generally, they could, on rare occasions they can even get to 10, but five to eight is about the ballpark. Yeah. Where is Megdalene at? Oh, she's young. I only got that last. year and I think she's not more than two. Oh no. You know, it's always hard to know how exactly old, how old your pets are when you get
她是，是的，是的。度过了非常非常充实的一生。所以虽然很伤心。嗯，豚鼠通常能活五年以上。一般来说，它们可以，在极少数情况下甚至能活到 10 岁，但 5 到 8 岁是大概的范围。是的。Magdalena 现在多大？哦，她还很年轻。我去年才得到她，我想她不超过两岁。哦，不。你知道，当你从救援中心领养宠物时，总是很难确切知道它们有多大。
them from rescue. Oh, no. So this is definitely not like age-related. This is just an unfortunate. No, this is a, well, hopefully it's a respiratory infection that she'll get over. Okay. Hopefully. Fingers crossed.
所以这绝对不是年龄相关的问题。这只是一个不幸的……不，这是一个……嗯，希望这只是一个她能挺过去的呼吸道感染。好的。希望如此。祈祷吧。
Anyway. Transitioning, yeah. I mean. That's all. Sorry to start with that. No, no. I mean, I'd rather, well, I wouldn't rather it be that, but I thought it was going to be, you know, there's a lot of stuff going on in the world right now that, you know, it's not the focus of this podcast,
总之。转换话题，是的。我是说。就这样。抱歉以这个开头。不，不。我是说，我宁愿……嗯，我也不希望是那样，但我以为会是……你知道，现在世界上发生了很多事情，你知道，这不是本期播客的重点。
but, yeah. Yeah, well. It's all terrible. We'll save it for one night we're in the boss and the world to write. Yeah, yeah. Hopefully everything turns out fine. Shima was talking about, I don't know, potentially trying to escape the snow, which we may or may not do. Oh, it's very cold up by you right now, is it?
但是，是的。是的，嗯。一切都很糟糕。我们留到哪天我们在老板那里或者世界要完蛋的时候再说吧。是的，是的。希望一切都会好起来。Shima 刚才在谈论，我不知道，可能想尝试逃离雪天，我们可能会也可能不会这样做。哦，你那边现在很冷，是吗？
Yeah, it's... It's been... It's been, like, minus 7 in Celsius at, like, it's warmest. At the warmest, okay, so... At the warmest. Minus 7 on its own is not that cold. It's not that bad. But, yeah, for a high, it's fairly cold.
是的，它……它一直……它一直，比如，最暖和的时候是零下 7 摄氏度。最暖和的时候，好的，所以……最暖和的时候。零下 7 度本身并不算太冷。还不算太糟。但是，是的，作为最高气温，这相当冷。
And it's been like that for two weeks, I'd say, and there was this crazy snowfall that happened to, like, all of the, whatever, northeastern North America. And so there's... I literally shoveled the snow like three or three or four times this one day when it snowed like, I don't know, three feet or something. And then it hasn't really snowed a lot since, but it's been very cold and it's been very demoralizing trying to run outside when it's like usually it's typically like minus 10 feels like minus 20. It's hard on the hands. Very hard on the hands. And I don't even have the right, like the, you're going to be like, why not just buy a good set of gloves?
而且这种情况已经持续两周了，我想，还有那场疯狂的降雪，发生在，比如，整个北美东北部。所以有……我有一天真的铲了三四次雪，当时雪下了，我不知道，三英尺左右。从那以后雪没怎么下，但一直很冷，而且在外面跑步非常令人沮丧，通常气温是零下 10 度，感觉像零下 20 度。对手来说很难受。对手来说非常难受。而且我甚至没有合适的，比如，你会说，为什么不买一副好的手套？
I have two like dollar store, you know, just like the cotton, like. So I wear two sets of those. It's fine once you get going. At minus 10 feels like minus 20s. Once you hit like the two kilometer mark, it's just the first two kilometers where you're like scrunching your hands to get the blood flowing. Anyways, we've recently ordered a treadmill because I can't, I can't do this. Indoor runs. It's nice to have the option.
我有两副那种一元店的，你知道，就是棉质的，比如。所以我戴两副。一旦跑起来就没事了。零下 10 度感觉像零下 20 度。一旦你跑到两公里左右，前两公里你只是在蜷缩双手让血液循环。总之，我们最近订了一台跑步机，因为我不能，我做不到。室内跑步。有这个选择很好。
Yeah. Anyways, this brings up because we're talking about the state of the world, and we were trying to look at options, and this may or may not even end up happening. And if it does, it's probably only going to be for a couple days. But we were thinking, like, well, I've never been to Florida. It's nice. But then we're like, well, this is America really a place we want to. If we've got multiple options, sure, it's close, but maybe fly an extra an hour or two and go somewhere else. So anyways.
是的。总之，这提到了，因为我们在谈论世界现状，我们试图寻找选择，这可能最终会发生，也可能不会。如果发生了，可能也只是几天。但我们在想，嗯，我从来没去过佛罗里达。那里不错。但后来我们想，嗯，美国真的是我们想去的地方吗？如果我们有多个选择，当然，它很近，但也许可以多飞一两个小时去别的地方。所以总之。
I've never been to Florida. It is somewhere, it is one of the three states that Brits know about. The others being Texas and California. That's funny. They also know about New York, but as a city, not a state. Oh, I was going to say, I assume you know of New York, but I guess that's true. No, I mean, you know, I've lived in the U.S. for over 20 years, so I know all the states, et cetera. but the average Britain on the street, as we know from watching British TV, various game shows, they don't have a good grasp of US geography.
我从来没去过佛罗里达。它是英国人知道的三个州之一。另外两个是德克萨斯州和加利福尼亚州。真有趣。他们也知道纽约，但作为城市，而不是州。哦，我正想说，我假设你知道纽约，但我猜那是真的。不，我是说，你知道，我在美国生活了 20 多年，所以我知道所有的州等等。但街上的普通英国人，正如我们从看英国电视、各种游戏节目中了解到的那样，他们对美国地理没有很好的掌握。
Yeah, I wonder what percentage of folks in the UK can name a second city in New York? In New York State? Yeah, yeah. What would your guess of that percentage be? In the general population, I don't know, low, pretty low, less than 20% probably. Interesting. I don't know. Yeah, and I don't know which city it would be because maybe Albany?
是的，我很好奇英国有多少比例的人能说出纽约的第二个城市？在纽约州？是的，是的。你猜这个比例是多少？在普通人群中，我不知道，很低，相当低，可能不到 20%。有趣。我不知道。是的，我不知道会是哪个城市，因为也许是奥尔巴尼（Albany）？
Yeah, I mean, the three that come to mind when I think of other New York cities are Albany, Syracuse, and Buffalo. Oh, yeah. I didn't even think of Buffalo. Buffalo has a football team. I was thinking of maybe like university towns like Ithaca. But I don't think they are. That's, for instance, in Ithaca, right? That is New York State.
是的，我是说，当我想到其他纽约城市时，脑海中浮现的三个是奥尔巴尼、雪城（Syracuse）和布法罗（Buffalo）。哦，是的。我甚至没想过布法罗。布法罗有一支橄榄球队。我当时在想也许是像伊萨卡（Ithaca）这样的大学城。但我不认为它们是。那是，例如，在伊萨卡，对吧？那是纽约州。
Right? I thought Princeton was in New Jersey, to be honest. So now I said that, I did too. I feel like there was some scene I saw in Oppenheimer or something I read in a book that gave me the impression that Princeton was in New Jersey. Maybe it's not Princeton that's in Ithaca. Maybe it's some other.
对吧？老实说，我以为普林斯顿在新泽西州。所以现在我说了，我也这么觉得。我觉得我在《奥本海默》里看到过某个场景，或者我在书里读到过什么，让我觉得普林斯顿在新泽西州。也许在伊萨卡的不是普林斯顿。也许是别的什么。
Anyway, Ithaca is in New York. Yeah, Syracuse is one. But these are ones that I don't think Brits would really know or they'll have heard of the city but they won't associate it of being in New York State. Right. You're right.
总之，伊萨卡在纽约州。是的，雪城是一个。但这些是我认为英国人不会真正知道的，或者他们听说过这个城市，但不会把它与纽约州联系起来。对。你是对的。
Princeton is in New Jersey. Why am I thinking of Ithaca? Well, it's a college town anyway. Yeah. Anyways, I sent you a number of things that I wanted to chat about. Where should we start? Or do you have things you want to chat about too?
普林斯顿在新泽西州。我为什么会想到伊萨卡？嗯，反正它是个大学城。是的。总之，我发给你了一些我想聊的事情。我们从哪里开始？或者你也有想聊的事情吗？
Well, one of the things you said, let's see here. I always love to talk about recreational math, recreational algorithms. that kind of thing because I think that's so important. You know, playing is so important to me throughout my life and still in my professional life. Just the idea of playing with code, seeing what's possible, trying things out. So I think we should talk about that. All right.
嗯，你说的其中一件事，让我们看看。我一直很喜欢谈论娱乐数学、娱乐算法，诸如此类的事情，因为我认为这非常重要。你知道，玩耍对我的一生以及现在的职业生涯都非常重要。仅仅是玩代码、看看什么是可能的、尝试各种事物的想法。所以我认为我们应该谈谈这个。好的。
I mean, this, so first question, have you, did you listen to my last accidentally solo episode last week because I didn't reach out to you. You better remind me of it. I did listen to it. It was basically talking about a couple algorithms and at the end, combinators used to solve the mastermind game. Okay.
我是说，这，所以第一个问题，你听了我上周那期意外的单人节目吗？因为我没联系你。你最好提醒我一下。我听了。它基本上是在谈论几个算法，最后是用来解决 Mastermind 游戏的组合子。好的。
Oh, yeah, mastermind. So the pure form of wordl. Yes, which like 10 seconds or 30 seconds into my explanation of the game, Mastermind. I was like, ah, it's kind of like Wardle. And then I realized, oh, wait, wordal is just... Yeah, Mastermind with extra constraints.
哦，是的，Mastermind。所以是 Wordle 的纯粹形式。是的，这就像我在解释 Mastermind 游戏 10 秒或 30 秒后。我就说，啊，这有点像 Wordle。然后我意识到，哦，等等，Wordle 只是……是的，带有额外约束的 Mastermind。
Yeah, Mastermind. with six guesses and words instead of colors with the constraint that it has to be a valid word. And there's the exact matches and the near matches. And the point of that ramble was just my realization that the motivation for the adjacent difference or the motivation for, yeah, adjacent difference in C++98 was Stepanov wanted two algorithms that could round trip. So there was like an analog. So partial sum and adjacent difference.
是的，Mastermind。有六次猜测机会，用单词代替颜色，并带有必须是有效单词的约束。还有精确匹配和近似匹配。那段漫谈的重点只是我意识到，C++98 中相邻差（adjacent difference）的动机是 Stepanov 想要两个可以往返的算法。所以有一个模拟。即部分和（partial sum）和相邻差。
Yeah. And if you do the my preferred, you know, more generic and pure version of adjacent difference that has n-minus-1 elements in the result, you can't round-trip. And I remember I mentioned Christabella, who I actually don't know if he still works at Google, but I believe at the time was working at Google when we were chatting about this and probably still does. And he was kind of taking the stance that it is the correct implementation of it. because that was Steppenov's motivation. And my feeling is that it shouldn't, even though that is a, I understand the motivation, it shouldn't have been a motivation. It should have been this more generic form.
是的。如果你做我偏好的，你知道，更通用和纯粹的相邻差版本，结果中有 n-1 个元素，你就无法往返。我记得我提到了 Christabella，我其实不知道他是否还在谷歌工作，但我相信当时我们聊这个的时候他在谷歌工作，可能现在还在。他当时持有的立场是，这是它的正确实现，因为那是 Stepanov 的动机。而我的感觉是，即使我理解那个动机，它也不应该成为动机。它应该采用这种更通用的形式。
And this ties back into recreational mathematics and quote unquote recreational algorithms, which isn't actually a term, but I just borrowed it from math and, you know, ported it to algorithms. Sure. is that my realization that the you can get adjacent difference with an inversion modifier in Wiiwa or one of these other array language is by inverting the plus scan, you get the exact behavior of adjacent difference, but then you also have the generic version of the map adjacent like from Haskell, which I want. You get both of those in an array language, but my realization of that came from the mastermind kata, which like I have a GitHub repo. I've implemented
这又回到了娱乐数学和所谓的娱乐算法，这不是一个真正的术语，但我只是从数学中借用它，你知道，移植到了算法中。当然。是我意识到，你可以在 Wiiwa 或其他数组语言中通过对加法扫描（plus scan）进行逆运算修饰符来得到相邻差，你得到了相邻差的确切行为，但你同时也拥有像 Haskell 那样的通用映射相邻（map adjacent）版本，这是我想要的。你在数组语言中两者兼得，但我对这一点的认识来自于 Mastermind kata，我有一个 GitHub 仓库。我已经用，我不知道多少种不同的语言实现了它。出于一些不重要的原因，我正在用 Wii 重做它。然后我有了这个认识。然后这让我想到，我们并没有真正谈论，我是说，我们有时谈过，但你刚才说的这个想法，比如玩耍。我甚至提交过一两次关于“娱乐算法”的演讲。但每次都被拒绝了。因为，比如，那个演讲的描述是什么，你知道，展示如何，你知道，小的琐碎问题，你知道，那些不重要的，可以引出重要的见解。比如，很多人看到这个，他们会说，哪里有，你知道，我需要一些关于单元测试框架的东西，或者我需要一些关于最新和
it in like, I don't know how many different languages. And for reasons that don't matter, I was redoing it in Wii. And then I had this like realization. And then it made me think that we don't really talk about, I mean, we have at times, but this idea of what you just said, like playing around. And I even submitted, I think, once or twice the talk recreational algorithms. And every time it's been rejected. Because like, what is the description of that talk, you know, showing how, you know, small trivial problems, you know, that are non-importants can lead to important insights. Like, a lot of people see that and they're like, where's the, you know, I need something about a unit testing framework or I need something about the latest and
最伟大的 C++20x 特性的东西。总之，所以我知道你是巨大的支持者。所以我把它列入了清单。我相信我们可以轻松地谈论 30 分钟或 60 分钟。嗯，所以我想问你，你说对加法扫描进行逆运算。你是什么意思？通过逆运算。这是内置在语言里的吗？这是一个组合子还是一个允许你进行逆运算的字形（glyph）？是的。在 Wiwa 中，它是如何工作的？作为较新的语言之一，他们称之为修饰符，我相信大多数语言现在都称它们为修饰符。它不完全是一个组合子。所以大多数数组语言都有某种东西，一个操作符或修饰符，你可以把它看作是一个高阶函数，叫做幂（power）或重复（repeat），
greatest C++20x feature. Anyway, so I know that you are a huge proponent. So I put it on the list. And I'm sure we could easily talk about for 30 minutes or 60 minutes. Well, so I wanted to ask you, you said inverting plus scan. How do you mean? by inverting. Is that built into the language? Is that a combinator or a glyph that allows you to invert? Yeah. In Wiwa, though, how does that work? One of the more recent languages, they call it a modifier, and I believe most languages call them modifiers now. It's not exactly a combinator. So most array languages have something, an operator or a modifier, which is you can think of as a higher a higher order function called power or repeat,
它接受一个函数和一个整数，然后它会重复它。所以我认为在 Haskell 中有一个迭代器。我想是右侧的。所以这就是你所想的，它是 F of X，F of F of X 等等。是的。
which takes a function and then an integer, and it'll repeat that. So I think in Haskell there's a iterator. It's a right, I think. So that's the one you're thinking of where it's F of X, F of F of X, etc. Yeah.
好的。而且当你应用到像二元函数时，会有一些细微差别。但我们只关注一元情况，你只有一个参数函数，你知道，你在对某事求平方。如果你做三次，现在就是无论什么，求平方三次。大多数数组语言都有能力用负一调用幂或重复，这有点……我明白了。好的，所以那是对函数进行逆运算。是的。我曾经和 Bryce 谈过这个，他当时问，那怎么工作？这实际上只是，比如
Okay. And there's this kind of slightly, there's some nuances when you get to applying that to like a diatic function. But we'll just focus on like the unary case here where you just got one argument function, you know, you're squaring something. If you do it three times, it's now whatever, squared three times. And most array languages have the ability to call power or repeat with negative one, which is kind of... I see. Okay, so that's inverting the function. Yeah. And I talked about this with Bryce once and he was like, well, how does that work? And it's really just like
实现定义的，对吧？所以如果一个惯用法或原语……哦，我明白了。所以它必须支持逆运算。是的。好的。在 J 语言中，它创建于 1990 年，类似于 APL 2.0，它是 APL 的 ASCII 版本。我知道你知道这个。我是在为听众解释。他们引入了幂操作符和逆运算。然后他们还提供了一种叫做“反向（obverse）”的东西，它让你能够为你编写的函数定义一个逆函数。所以，好的。它，我其实不知道你怎么称呼那个。
implementation defined, right? So if a idiom or a primitive... Oh, I see. So it has to support inversion. Yes. Okay. And in the J language, which was created in 1990, kind of APL 2.0, it's the ASCII version of APL. I know you know this. I'm explaining for the listener. They introduced the power operator and inverse. And then they also provided something called obverse, which gives you the ability to define an inverse for a function that you've written. So, okay. It's, I don't actually know what you call that.
你说的是 obverse？Obverse，是的。O-B-V-E-R-S-E。Abverse，是的，是他们添加的原语，这样你就可以定义你自己的逆函数。所以，我是说，这对于一个激进的术语来说有点像黑客行为，因为我真的，真的非常喜欢。
Did you say obverse? Obverse, yes. O-B-V-E-R-S-E. Abverse, yes, was the primitive that they added so that you can define your own inverse. So, I mean, this is a little bit of a hack for an aggressive term, because I really, really like. the inverse behaviors that are implemented like another one
那些被实现的逆行为，就像另一个我之前在节目中指出或提到的，是我在数组语言中最喜欢的原语之一，叫做“where”或“indices”，给定一个由 1 和 0 组成的序列，它会返回对应于 1 的索引，所以对吧，你知道，这是一种压缩，有点像
that I've pointed out or brought up on the show before is one of my favorite primitives in array languages is called where or indices it given a sequence
一个，是的，过滤、拉链宽度（zip width）或枚举的组合。如果你对那个操作进行逆运算，在一个排序数字列表上，
of ones and zeros it'll return you back the indices that correspond to the ones so right you know it's a type of compaction kind of like
你会得到生成该结果的掩码。然后有很多，你知道，有点像，你知道，挥手示意，比如，嗯，技术上讲，如果数组末尾有一堆零怎么办？比如，你不能确定性地一对一地总是得到相同的结果。所以有些事情人们会说，嗯，如果你想在学术上非常正确，你不应该对这个进行逆运算，
a yeah a filter zip width or enumerate kind of combined and And if you do an inverse on that operation, on a list of sorted numbers,
因为你没有这些所谓的全函数（total functions）之类的。所以逆运算的属性是，它应该是可往返的。函数应该与其逆函数可往返。你会说这是一个，如果不是一个，嗯，我们说这是一个值得追求的属性。它可能不适用于每个实现，但我认为它肯定在指南中。是的。它不比这更强。
you get back the mask that would generate that for you. And then there's a lot of like, you know, kind of hand-waving is like, well, technically, what if there's a bunch of zeros at the end of an array? Like, you can't deterministically one-to-one always get the same results. So there's certain things where people are like, well, if you want to be really like academically correct, you shouldn't have an inverse on this
是的，如果那不是正确的学术定义，从理解的角度来看，它绝对是它的本质。所以有很多函数的逆函数被实现为它们自身。你能想到几个，对吧？比如反转（reverse）是。是的，当然。它只是它自己的逆函数。但这很有趣，因为诱惑，所以这很有趣，因为有时会有诱惑说出像
because you don't have these like total functions or whatever you call them. So the property of inverse then is that it should be round-trippable. Functions should be round-trippable with its inverse. Would you say that's a, if not a, well, let's say it's a property to be desired. It might not be the case for every implementation, but I'd imagine it's certainly, in the guidelines. Yes. It's not stronger than that.
除法和乘法是逆运算这样的话，这当然是不正确的，因为它们从根本上定义在不同的事物上。我们会详细说明。我是说，我知道你在说什么，但为了听众着想。你知道，当我们想到折叠时，就会想到折叠和展开之类的东西。你会想到幺半群，对吧？然后你会想到整数加法，比如说，对吧？然后你会想，加法的逆运算是什么？
Yeah, if that's not the correct, yeah, academic definition, it's from a understanding point of view, definitely the essence of it. So there's a lot of functions that have their inverses implemented as just themselves. You could think of a couple, right? Like reverse is. Yeah, sure. It's just its own inverse. But it's interesting because the temptation, so this is interesting because there's a temptation sometimes to say things
嗯，你会想到减法，但它其实和加法是一回事，只不过是用负数来表示，我想是这样。所以从那里，你得到一个概念，即逆元是集合中的一个元素。它不是一个函数，对吧？所以情况就是这样。也许这不是你想问的，但我刚才想到了另一件事。比如，如果我们讨论幺半群，然后将其扩展到半群和群，那么逆元的概念就不是指你有一个逆运算，
like division and multiplication are inverses, which is, of course, not true, because they are defined over different things fundamentally. We'll expound on that. I mean, I know what you're saying, but for the listener's sake. You know, when we think about folds, it comes up with folds and unfolds and things like that. You think about monoids, right? And you think about the addition over the integers, let's say, right? And then you think, what's the inverse of addition?
而是指你的集合中存在该运算的逆元素。好的，所以这又要回到范畴论了，所以我们得在这里慢一点。嗯，其实不用。我是说，我不想完全进入范畴论。我们只是在这里谈论常规的幺半群和群。这不一定完全进入范畴论的完全抽象。所以，当然，每个人学习的前两个幺半群，
Well, you think subtraction, but it's really the same thing as addition, just with the negative numbers, I guess. And so from there, you get the idea of, like, the inverse is an element of the set. It's not a function, right? So there's that. Maybe that's not what you were asking, but there's something else that just occurred to me. Like, if we're talking about monoids and then extending that to semi-groups and groups, then the idea of an inverse is not that you have an inverse operation,
嗯，其中之一，前两个中的几个是加法和乘法，对吧？在整数上，对吧？所以在那之前，当你接触到这一点时，你可能已经把加法和减法看作某种逆运算了。但当你学习幺半群和群时，你就学到了，好的，不一定是运算，
but that you have inverse elements in your set for the operation. All right, so this is going back to category theory, so we're going to have to slow down here for a sec. Well, not really. I mean, I don't want to go full category theory. We're just talking about regular monoids and groups here. This is not fully into total abstraction of category theory, necessarily. And so then, of course, the first two monoids everyone learns all,
是逆运算，而是集合中的成员在该运算下有逆元。所以，你知道，如果你不采取那种观点，继续试图认为函数有逆函数，那么它可能会引导你思考诸如，嗯，除法是乘法的逆运算。
well, one of the first, a couple of the first two are addition and multiplication, right? on the integers, right? And so up until that point in your life, probably when you come to that, you've thought of addition and subtraction as sort of inverse operations. But then when you learn about monoids and groups, then you learn, okay, it's not necessarily the operation,
这只是，我不认为那是真的，对吧？因为它不是定义在同一个集合上的。你不能除以零，对吧？所以乘法，你知道，有理数在乘法下为集合中的某些元素提供了逆元，对吧？或者倒数提供了，对吧？但你可以乘以零，你不能除以零。
which is the inverse, it's that the members of the set have inverses under this operation. And so, you know, if you don't take that view and you continue to try and think of functions as having inverses, then it can lead you to think about things like, well, division is the inverse of multiplication.
嗯，各位，让我们看看我们能不能。所以这可能与你问的问题有不同的切入点，也就是说，函数在某种意义上有逆函数是完全没问题的，对吧，但我们需要小心。这才是重点。所以，我是说，这会进入，我们会分享我的屏幕，但我们不会犯让听众听不下去的错误，我最近在我的另一个播客 Tasset Talk 上就这么做了。我忘了有些人只听音频。所以，我是说，如果我们去 BQN，我们做，你知道，1 加 1，我们得到 2。
And that is just, I don't think that's true, right? Because it's not defined over the same set. You cannot divide by zero, right? And so multiplication, you know, and the rational numbers give inverses to some, some elements of the set under multiplication, right? Or reciprocals do, right? But you can multiply by zero, you can't divide by zero.
但如果我们做 1 或者我猜它叫撤销（undo），我们会得到 0。所以从技术上讲，这在数学上是不正确的，这是加法的逆运算，对吧？是的，是减法。所以碰巧在这种情况下，你可以，你可以那样做，对吧，这就是我说的，没问题。
Well, folks, let's see if we can. So this is maybe a different tangent to what you were asking, which is to say that it's perfectly fine for functions to have inverses, right, in some sense, but we need to be careful. That's really the point. So, I mean, this is going to get into, we'll share my screen, but we won't make the mistake of making this unlistenable for the listener, which I did recently do on my other podcast, Tasset Talk. I forgot that some people listen to these things, audio only. So, I mean, if we go to BQN and we do, you know, one plus one, we get two.
是的，你可以把加法的逆运算看作减法，之所以能这样做，是因为它们精确地定义在相同的集合上。嗯，所以这就是重点。所以我们要朝着那些没有定义的地方努力。所以如果我们把加号换成乘号，
but if we do one or I guess it's called undo we're going to get zero so technically this is mathematically incorrect this is this is the inverse
我是说，我猜我们必须改变这些数字。我猜这应该是 1。所以 1 乘以 2 是 2。但如果我们做 1 乘以撤销 2，那么你会期望一半是多少。哦，是的，你会期望。一半，但它给了你 2。这根本说不通。
of plus yes is minus so it happens in this case that you can you can do that right that's what I'm saying it's fine
我原以为这会说这是一个一半。嗯，什么，它叫重复吗？所以，我是说，如果我们做，我猜我们需要这里的数字，哦是的，因为我们有 2。所以现在我展示的是我有 1 乘以重复 2，2，这只是令人困惑。它给出了 2。虽然，我猜这说得通，是的。然后我们有 2 乘以重复 2，2，这给出了 8，因为你在做乘法。所以乘以重复 2 是 2 的 3 次方。
yes you can look at the inverse addition as subtraction and the reason you can do that is because they are defined precisely over the same sets. Well, so that's the thing. So we're going to work our way to the ones where it's not defined. So if we switch our plus to a multiplies,
是 2 乘以。所以那是平方两次。如果你取 2 并平方两次，不，不是平方两次。那会得到 16。所以这是除法。为什么这没起作用？所以我们现在有 2 乘以重复负 1，2。这是另一种方式，如果你说重复负 1，那是拼写撤销的另一种方式。
I mean, I guess we have to change these numbers. I guess this should be one. So it's one times two is two. But if we do one times undo two, then you would expect half is what. Oh, yeah, you would expect. half, but it's giving you two. That doesn't make sense at all.
这给了你 1。所以 2 乘以逆 2，也就是 2 除以 2 是 1。但如果我们把它换成 1 乘以撤销，也就是 1 乘以逆，它只是给了我们 2。所以这很令人困惑。但我正在努力实现的是，如果你去 1 乘以 0，你得到 0。但如果你得到 1 乘以撤销，也就是逆，会发生什么？这也没给我想要的。所以它只是给出了 0。
I was expecting this to say that this was a half. Well, what is, is it called repeat? So, I mean, if we do, I guess we need numbers here to, oh yeah, because we have two. So right now what I'm showing is I have one times repeat two, two, which is just confusing. It gives two. Although, I guess that makes sense, yeah. And then we have two times repeat two, two, that gives eight because you're multiplying. So the times repeat two is two to the power of three.
所以也许有什么东西说如果……我是说，是的。我是说，这是计算机。它们不是，你知道，整数不是数学上的整数，浮点数不是实数。我们在计算中可以自由定义事物。我所说的是，这并没有使它在数学上正确。它可能很实用。这正是那个词。
Is two multiplies. So that's squaring it twice. If you take two and square it twice, no, not squaring it twice. That would get 16. So this is division. Why did this not work? So we now have two times repeat negative one, two. which is another way, if you say repeat negative 1, that's another way of spelling undo.
所以存在这种实用主义与……Marshall，BQN 的实现者用的那个词是什么？我们会用像“数学上正确”或“学术上正确”这样的词。而其中一些数组语言选择做一些在增加原语有用性方面更务实或更实际的事情。所以你刚才写了 1 除以 0，答案是无穷大？是的。根据 BQN。
And this gives you 1. So 2 multiplies inverse 2, aka 2 divided by 2 is 1. But if we switch it to 1 times undo, aka 1 multiplies inverse, it just gives us 2. So this is confusing. But what I was working up to was if you go 1 times 0, you get 0. but what happens if you get one times undo, aka inverse? This doesn't give me what I want either. So it just gives zero.
这显然是不正确的。但也许很务实。是的，所以总之，我很困惑。我以后会向你汇报。为什么，当任何……嗯，所以什么是 0 乘以无穷大？我是说，你能问 EQA 吗？哦。
So maybe there's some thing that says if... I mean, yeah. I mean, this is computers. They're not, you know, ints aren't integers, floats aren't real numbers. We're free to define things in computing. What I'm saying is it doesn't make it mathematically correct. It makes it practical, perhaps. That is exactly the word.
它只是说……它只是说 1 除以 0 是无穷大。0 乘以无穷大不是一个数字。相当，也许很明智。所以，你知道，我们刚刚证明了乘法和除法在 BQN 中不是逆运算。是的。无穷大乘以无穷大是无穷大，而无穷大除以无穷大不是一个数字。对。
So there is this pragmatic versus... What is the word that Marshall, the implementer of BQN? We'll use the word like mathematically correct or academically correct. And some of these array languages choose to do things that are more pragmatic or practical in terms of increasing the usefulness of a primitive. So you've just written 1 divided by 0, and the answer is infinity? Yes. According to BQN.
因为实际上，无穷大本身不是一个数字，对吧？从数学上讲。对。或者我假设也许是另一种数字。我不知道。顺便说一句，你应该知道，我所有的。基本上我所有的数学知识在这一生中都是娱乐性的。出于某种原因，人们看到我的演讲，他们认为我懂数学。但事实上，他们中的大多数人在形式上比我有更多的
Which is clearly incorrect. but maybe pragmatic. Yeah, so anyways, I'm confused. I will report back to you in the future. Why, when any... Well, so what's zero times infinity? I mean, can you ask EQA? Oh.
数学训练。我不想在大学里做比我需要的更多的微分方程。所以这就是我的数学训练基本结束的地方。我觉得仅仅因为某人受过更正规的训练或在生活中修过更多的数学课程，并不一定等同于以后的生活。我想象你保留并在后台积极思考的数量至少高于平均水平。对于普通人群来说，高于平均水平，当然。对于程序员来说，高于平均水平，也许，我不知道。但是是的，回到那个想法，仅仅，你知道，我认为仅仅通过在这里玩耍，我们可能发现了一些东西，
It just said that... It just said one divided by zero is infinity. Zero times infinity is not a number. Quite, maybe sensibly. So, you know, we've just proved that multiplication and division are not inverses in BQN. Yeah. Infinity times infinity is infinity, and infinity divided by infinity was not a number. Right.
或者你发现了一些意想不到的有趣的东西，也许。我是说，我不是 BQN 用户，但你更经常使用它。所以你脑子里对它应该如何表现有一些想法，我们刚才输入的一些东西可能让你感到惊讶，所以这很棒，对吧，因为是谁说的，是 Isaac Asimov 说的吗，你知道，学习的开始，科学中最令人兴奋的短语不是“尤里卡”，而是“真奇怪”。真奇怪。总之，我在播客中间阅读文档可能不是 ADSP 最好的收听体验，呃，死气沉沉的男人，死气沉沉。
Because actually, infinity itself is not a number, right? Mathematically speaking. Right. Or I suppose maybe a different kind of number. I don't know. You should know that, by the way, all of my. basically all of my mathematics is recreational at this point in my life. For some reason, people see my talks and they think I know mathematics. But in fact, most of them have more
但总之，是的，我原以为 BQN 会，对于 1 乘以 0 的逆运算会给出无穷大。但它没有。所以我们确实学到了一些东西。这是一个算法见解吗？是的，并不完全是。当你玩耍或玩得开心时，你并不总是会有那些见解。请务必查看这些节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用程序中还是在 ADSP 播客上。获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。
mathematical training than me in a formal sense. I didn't want to do more differential equations than I needed to at university. So that's where my mathematical training ends pretty much. I feel like just because someone's more formally trained or has taken more, you know, math courses in their life, though, doesn't necessarily equate to later in life. I would imagine that the amount that you have retained and actively, like, think about in the background is probably above average at a minimum. Above average for the general population, certainly. above average for programmers, maybe, I don't know. But yes, back to the idea that just, you know, I think just by playing here, we've maybe discovered something,
感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。我是反 Bryce。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
or you've discovered something interesting that was unexpected, maybe. I mean, I'm not a BQN user, but you use this much more often. So you have some idea in your head of how it should behave, and some of the things we've just typed seem to have maybe surprised, so that's that's great right because who was it who said was it Isaac Asimov who said you know the beginning of learning the most the most exciting phrase in science is not eureka but that's odd that's odd anyways me reading the documentation in the middle of a podcast is probably not the best listening experience for the ADSP uh dead air man dead air
或者你可能发现了什么意想不到的有趣之处。我是说，我不是 BQN 用户，但你用得比我多得多。所以你脑子里对它应该如何表现有一些预设，而我们刚才输入的一些东西似乎让你感到惊讶，这很好，对吧？因为是谁说的来着，是艾萨克·阿西莫夫吗？他说科学中最令人兴奋的短语不是“尤里卡”，而是“真奇怪”。不管怎样，我在播客中间读文档可能不是最好的听觉体验，ADSP 的听众们，呃，冷场了，伙计，冷场了。
But anyways, yes, I was expecting the BQN to, for one multiplies inverse of zero to give infinity. But it does not. So we indeed did learn something. Was it an algorithmic insight? Yeah, not really. You're not always going to have those when you're playing around or having fun. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast. for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions.
但不管怎样，是的，我原本以为 BQN 会让一乘以零的倒数得到无穷大。但它并没有。所以我们确实学到了一些东西。这算是一种算法上的洞察吗？嗯，算不上。当你只是在玩耍或寻找乐趣时，并不总会有那种洞察。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSP 播客网站上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个可以让你留下想法、评论和问题的 GitHub 讨论链接。
Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有愉快的一天。我是反括号。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。